learners permit thursday is on my
youtube subscribe today the night pants
nation tour continues arlington november
11th through the 13th cleveland december
9th through the 11th and la jolla
december 17th through the 19th all
tickets are available at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media
listen if i'm coming to your city and
i'm coming arlington virginia get your
tickets to the night pants nation tour
we've already had killer weeks in
phoenix in indy in baltimore in brea now
i'm hitting arlington virginia after
that coming in cleveland after that
boom la jolla all right that's our 2021
so come out get your tickets at
ryansickler.com
uh and thank you again for your support
for this show i love seeing this thing
grow
um it's just i love my job and i love
sitting here listening and talking to
everybody highlight their low light so
please hit that subscribe button again i
say it means nothing you and everything
to us all right also the patreon
continues to grow every month it gets
bigger um
it's the wildest [ __ ] i've ever heard
well i told you we had a girl with two
[ __ ] she came to meet me in baltimore
one [ __ ] now she's the best i [ __ ]
love it we're solving cold cases we got
people who clean up murders we got
people getting brains blown out in front
of them on them okay we got all kinds of
people figuring out their dad ain't
their dad we got people doing all kinds
of [ __ ] out there it is the best show
going right now it's five bucks a month
if you sign up for a year you get a
month free all right and you get the
honeydew a day early ad free at no
additional cost okay uh so if you or
someone you know has this story that has
to be heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com so we can get
on and highlight the low lights with
y'all all right there it is that's the
biz and you know what we do over here we
highlight the low lights with you all i
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers i'm very excited to
have this guest on here his first time
here ladies and gentlemen please welcome
eddie if y'all welcome to the honeydew
eddie if thanks i i you know i've
listened to your podcast but i never
really thought of it as though that's
what you do and i was like ah when you
were like hey what do you want to talk
about i'm like
there's so many
well i get some people like we can just
talk about whatever i'm like nah that's
not this podcast we're not talking about
whatever we're talking about some of the
worst [ __ ]
that you've had in your life i'm
generally a happy person yeah you always
seem happy when i see you and i feel
like i've been very lucky i've had a
very good life but there are many
i'm getting old i've had a lot of how
old are you now
just turned 50. did you really yep oh
congrats bro 50. all right you look
[ __ ] great dude yeah i told somebody
the other day they go how do you i got
38.
and they didn't flinch they didn't go
oh come on you know they were just like
and i i thought it was kind of funny and
then i was telling my wife that today
and my wife is
not even 30 she's 37. and when i said it
i was like oh this must be weird to her
because
you know she is
right yeah she's like no
and i'm like
i'm old
well um before we begin promote
everything you'd like to promote and
then we're gonna
chat it up love the promotion part this
is my favorite part no uh i am on tour
starting this week
i go out every single weekend until
uh mid-february all right and i am uh in
a different city every week it's all at
eddief.com i am from anchorage alaska
down to key west florida i am covering
the whole country and uh
have to make up for the last 15 months
and i'm also shooting a special on
january 22nd
at the irvine improv all right in
california so that will be my new
special which tentatively is gonna be
called manchild
and it's about how i basically want to
keep living as a child and never
take anything seriously
i am peter pan i don't want any
responsibility i don't want to
i just want to have fun well let's talk
about because you want to talk about
something very specific i i say some
people come in with a life story some
people come in and talk about a specific
struggle but this one's interesting to
me because it's a career thing yeah um
so tell me what happened things are
going well enough and we're talking
about in comedy or was this the shift to
get into comedy
life was hard for me up until comedy
like every nothing came easy for me i
was a failure at pretty much everything
what what some of the things you tried
that you failed at like school i was i
was but i if i was going to be the bad
at i'd be the worst okay like i was
kicked out of grade school high school
college everything you were for oh yeah
um
grade school when they said i took a wig
off a nun but i didn't no i didn't do it
i
and
but that's what they said they said i
did because
to this day everyone still says i did it
even kids that were there
like eddie if did it not because it's
that like berenstain bear thing yeah
then what is it the men's
i have no problem saying it was mark
drischler did it mark
and
i remember when it happened
i was like we were supposed to do it
together and i wasn't man enough to do
it mark was like and i think mark was
kind of an orphan
and i was like come on you you know you
won't get in as much trouble as i will
yeah yeah yeah
i have people because we had gotten in
trouble prior to that i went to a
catholic school we got in trouble for
one day our teacher said hey uh we're
going to make this uh we're going to all
divide up in groups and we're going to
make an organization and you're going to
run your organization what it does it's
going to be like religiously affiliated
and blah blah blah forget what class was
so me and my friends
made the cr this is eighth grade we made
the christian united nations together
i smelled it in my head
we were the gods
you're the [ __ ] and we had a our emblem
was a triangle
with lips in the middle come on man
swear to god and our teacher's name was
sister colette who we used to constantly
call sister [ __ ]
we would like you would raise your hand
you go sister [ __ ] sister sister
sister [ __ ] sister [ __ ]
and
she was she was mean she was an evil
woman
evil
and
her she would
she'd called us all bud she'd like bud
bud bud and i just hated being called
butt i remember she slammed one of my
friends was under his desk she slammed
the desk on his hands she was all it's
just very mean
and so i didn't
we knew she had a wig we would walk
behind her we would see it we would
touch it sometimes and play with it when
we're standing behind her
and we're like what's longer hair like
is a long nose big curly gray wig but
she's a habit or like no she don't wear
a habit but they i think that's what
happens is they wear habits for so long
it kind of makes look i know now this
was very cruel and mean like i was a
little kid didn't understand that i i
realized it was mean right after it
happened i'll tell you that uh
but we i saw that like we just joke we
call her wiggy like that was our
nickname for wiggy and everybody's like
wait so the whole thing was like we're
gonna take wiggy's wig off and we're
gonna run it up the flagpole that's what
we're gonna do
so we had a whole plan we left our bikes
outside we're gonna ride away on our
bikes and
um
so we waited for the day to do it and
everybody talked about it it was like
build up forever and mark i can't
believe he did it to this day that he
had the balls to do it he ran up behind
her i think i distracted her or
something so i was involved but he did
it and he ran away with it like he
snatched it off her head yeah and he got
on his bike and he rode away i actually
got on the bus
it gets worse
let me get on the slowest moving [ __ ]
thing
i gotta wait for it i got on the school
bus with my brother and two girl friends
of mine
and the girls had brought eggs on the
bus and we egged the crossing guard on
the way home
and his name was mr christophic
and we called him mr
christopher and
this is catholic school this is catholic
schools
and like so he worked our lunch time he
was our recess kind of like
guy that over sauce and he was
you know you feel like these guys are
authoritarian and they're mean and
everything and so then at like the
second or third stop of the bus
there was an intersection and he worked
there crossing it and we just windows
down just this is after the wig incident
but i remember after the wig came off i
was like jumping up and down the streets
laughing so hard and a girl who i kind
of like
didn't have a crush on but like looked
up to and respected and
you know
great family everything who was a friend
of mine
just came up to me and like shoved me
and was like why would you do that like
that was terrible that was and everybody
else was laughing and she kind of like
gave me this eye contact where i went
and i just felt so small like why did i
why did i do why was i involved in this
and
so they said that i was too immature to
go on in school so they sent me back to
eighth grade again no yeah so i had to
repeat eighth grade for that i had to
repeat eighth grade so i went to a
public school then for eighth grade
they were they were gonna oh that's not
when the military school thing happened
they were gonna send me to that school
we're about we're about not to talk
about anything you thought you were
gonna come in here
military school it's like they're all
right
i've never
so you got excuse me so now you're in a
public school repeating the eighth the
grade you just said you're in and my mom
said i never brought a book home and i
was like why should i i already did this
and uh when they had parent-teacher
conferences they called
everyone in you know like all the
parents would come in and you would go
room to room and meet with each teacher
my parents came home from the very first
parent teacher conference and said that
like there was like a special room that
all the teachers came to and it was just
my parents and they sat around them and
they were like they met your parents
yeah i wouldn't meet the teacher
yeah it was me that is my dad goes the
janitor and the cafeteria lady are there
like they're like the janitors
the crossing guards
they're like these kids
they thought there was something like
seriously psychologically wrong with me
so they
they said he can't come back i remember
my mom crying my mom coming home and
crying it made me so sad because i
actually liked the public school and i
liked all my friends
and she's like they don't want you back
like you can't come back and i was like
what are we gonna do now and my dad's
like i'll tell you what we're gonna do
and uh
my dad was like you're gonna go to
military school you went from catholic
school to military school yeah
and uh i got scared i was like i don't
want to go to military school i don't
and so i threatened my parents i was
where is this what state it is i was in
pittsburgh but they were going to send
me to valid forge military academy in
philadelphia where they filmed taps yep
and
i had just remembered the movie taps
because like the hutton yeah
movie uh great line from that uh sean
penn when he auditioned for fast times
at ridgemont high and the director asked
him what part he played in taps he goes
i was the conscience of the film
who says that it like 20 years old
they're all auditions
i was the conscience of the film anyway
it looked so scary to me i was like
i i just don't find any fun in that at
all so i was like i'll go awol and i was
like if you send me there
i will jump the fence you're telling
your dad yeah i would jump the fence and
you will never see me again and i
promise you like you cannot do this to
me
so there was this other school they
might have sent me to and
finally they were the school basically
said if i went and got like
psychologically tested
then the public saw a psychiatrist and
they did they would let me back in if
they figured it out
so i went and got tested and
they're like yeah he's okay you know
he's just a kid let him [ __ ] back in
so i got back in
and then
high school i got kicked out a bunch of
times never like
never like really permanently i mean
there was one time that was kind of
like
and it was a public school so like where
do you go after public school there's
nowhere to go
and uh
back to like failure and everything i
honestly tried at school like i was bad
but i think like just being bad i said
all the teachers off pissed everyone up
that no will give me a chance
so but i just couldn't understand how
bad of this struggle was
and
luckily
i found out right around my junior year
that i was pretty good at track at like
110 meter high hurdles
and one of the coaches sat me down a
football coach who also coached track
and he was like listen you suck at
football
like you were playing at least yeah yeah
i was playing i was always like six man
on the basketball team or like you know
i was like okay on the football i was
never good or great and i always i think
i wanted to be great
and i couldn't i just couldn't be and
this coach sat me down and he was like
stop playing football you're not going
to college on a scholarship no one's
going to take you it's not doing
anything for you and he goes and you're
going to get hurt and you have a chance
of going to school on a scholarship on
track like you're good
and i made the state championships and
literally like the track coach from the
university of pittsburgh came to my
my last track practice before i went to
the state championships and he was like
are you gonna [ __ ] up if we let you in
and i was like i promise i promise i
won't like please let me in please i
promise i won't [ __ ] up anymore. he's
like all right we're gonna let you in
you know you're gonna come run for us
but on scholarship i i ran on a small
scholarship in the beginning and i ended
up losing it later uh that's another
story but why
it's there's so much like what did you
do to have your scholarship yeah i don't
want to get into it because
no it involves like
don't if you can't say it don't say it
it's just there was an argument over
like who deserved it and who didn't and
i felt like the i felt like there was
someone was being rewarded that i was
beating all the time and i didn't think
they were getting it for me there was
underlying circumstances for them
getting it so it was a long story but
but college the whole time i was running
track i was in the fraternity just
getting drunk every [ __ ] day and i
wasn't still going out yeah i wasn't
doing well at track because i was like
time to party
and
so i wasn't focused because i i there
were like two people at my track mates
i'd go to track meets and there'd be
like two people in the crowds and i'm
like there were more in my high school
track mates this sucks and i'm riding a
bus and i was the only white kid on the
team and they were like abusing me for a
while and uh
uh then they got to be i got to be
really good friends with all the guys on
the track team but uh
i just liked
partying more i was like i'm gonna party
all the way through college so i got
kicked out of college for starting a
skydiving club and
you started a skydiving club i started
the panth panther skydiving club
i was hoping you bring back the [ __ ]
i shut up
i can't believe in eighth grade we were
the i can't even listen in high school
we did a talent show where we were the
floating seamen
s-e-a-m-e-n okay
and we wore uh no one caught you no one
caught it no we had a wave across the
whole front of the [ __ ] stage that
said the floating semen
and we wore um
four of us we wore like those orange
life preservers no shirts and a pair of
shorts and did and did a routine to
super freak literally like like five
days before m.c hammer's version came
out we couldn't even get over it and no
one ever [ __ ] caught it but it's on
vhs somewhere out there somewhere out
there the floating seamen yeah
there's so much innuendo
i mean in eighth grade we were at least
i think we were seniors we had a group
when i was a freshman i think it was a
senior showed up at a dance one time a
halloween dance dressed as ghosts
but they were clearly clan members
yeah like clearly
what's that patch on your ghost outfit
right there i mean the
pointiest hood just like just looked
exactly like a clean outfit and i
remember them catching them and saying
no like this is no this is back in 1990
you know or 1987 or something and they
were like no no out out and they're like
we're ghosts
and they're like no you're not get the
[ __ ] out of here but they never caught
the [ __ ] actually she did sister
collette caught the [ __ ] she took us in
the hallway she lined us all up in the
hallway made us sit close the door
everybody else in the room she's like
i've been a registered nurse for 70
years she she's so old she's like i
don't know how many years and she's like
and you think i don't know what this
symbol is because it was a triangle with
lips in the middle
i didn't even know what it was one of
the other guys like drew it i'm like
i've never seen a vagina you
know i love
it and she's like if you don't think i
know what this is and i know what you're
doing and uh
so she goes i want to know who's
responsible for this so she made us talk
amongst the like four or five of us and
figure out who did it
and uh who was responsible and i swear
we all like looked at mark trishler and
we're like mark
we all got parents you got to win
you got you got to take it yeah you got
to take it for the rest of us and he was
just like all right i got it and i mean
he just got
like they they went after him for this
and we were like sorry mark and then he
went no the wig was after that oh the
wig was there it was after the [ __ ]
and uh
uh but college panther skydiving club i
got kicked out and so um
i got back into college it was
i i basically embezzled money is what
they came after me for because i figured
out the system and i was involved
politically at college and all my
friends were all politically involved
and so it was like
i was just like a mobster i mean i was
like oh you mean you can get government
contracts it was the university of
pittsburgh okay and i was like wait so
if we just submit an application to the
allocations committee and we start a
group like i started a club
where we would go skydiving that's legal
but you're supposed to then advertise to
the entire university that they can join
your club can join
no ads
just me and my 10 buddies one one put
out a place one who didn't even go
go to pit and you get credits for this
too no you don't get credits but the
school pays for it like they give us
like thirty thousand dollars get the
[ __ ] i swear to god so we got allocated
all this skydiving so this is where it
gets a little weird the guy who went
with us my friend that didn't go to
college was camp kevin remember when
i've told you all about the guy with the
so kevin came with us
we go skydiving beaver valley skydiving
this like rinky dink location they've
got a bar there and i i wrote them a
check
for like the amount the total amount and
i said just we'll work it off
you know give us a credit and we can
show up whenever we want and jump out of
planes and you just take it off our
our thing and so they were like all
right give us the check you know and
they had a bar there so we would drink
at the bar and the school was paying for
it
but
you made a tab
yeah
oh you made a [ __ ] attack i feel like
i'm like nervous talking about this like
statute of limitations
[Laughter]
there are certain things in life that
are difficult to understand but knowing
how to feel your best shouldn't be one
of them everly well can help you learn
more about your body so you can finally
take control of your health and wellness
on your own time everly well offers
affordable at-home lab tests to give you
trusted physician-reviewed results
choose from tests including food
sensitivity metabolism sleep and stress
thyroid and so much more here's how it
works every well ships your test
straight to your door with everything
needed for a simple sample collection
you return the test to a clia certified
lab with a prepaid shipping label then
your physician reviewed results and
insights are sent to your device in just
days i did this all right over a million
people have trusted everly well with
their at-home lab testing and i did it
it's easy you prick your own finger you
just drop blood on the little card and
then you send it off after it dries out
and boom you get your results in a
couple days i got mine and i was
pleasantly surprised i did a food
sensitivity test and it was i was
sensitive to ginger
and like
there was a mild sensitivity to
something else that wasn't even really
relevant so nothing actually i was i was
excited to find that out uh but now i
know why i want to eat sushi my stomach
bothers me it's the ginger alright boom
thank you everybody well and for
listeners of the show everly wells
offering a special discount of 20 off
and at home lab test at everlywell.com
honeydew that's everlywell.com
honeydew for 20 off your at-home lab
test everlywell.com honeydew what if
getting your groceries put time back
into your week instead of taking it away
with the weather getting colder outside
stay cozy inside and let imperfect foods
deliver your intentionally sourced
groceries with just a few clicks and
perfect foods is a grocery delivery
service offering an entire line of
sustainable groceries that taste
delicious and reduce waste plus your
order will arrive on the same day each
week on average imperfect foods
customers save six to eight pounds of
food from lesser outcomes with every
order and unlike on-demand delivery
companies imperfect delivers weekly by
neighborhood a unique model that
produces 25 to 75 percent fewer
emissions than individual trips to the
grocery store and goodbye to packaging
guilt imperfect foods is the only
national grocery delivery company that
makes it easy to return your packaging
after every order they sent me a box of
stuff i got eggs i got peppers i got
cheese i got mushrooms i had so much
stuff and then my neighbor jen i was
like you got to try this stuff out she
cooked it all up and it was delicious
right now imperfect foods is offering my
listeners 20 off your first four orders
when you go to imperfect
imperfectfoods.com and use the promo
code honeydew again that's 20 off your
first four orders that's up to an 80
value at
imperfectfoods.com when you use promo
code honeydew
imperfectfoods.com and use code honeydew
with so many stressors in life it's
difficult to maintain effective
nutritional habits and give our bodies
the nutrients it needs to thrive ag-1 by
athletic greens the category-leading
superfood product brings comprehensive
and convenient daily nutrition to
everybody and to help each of us be our
best they simplify the path to better
nutrition by giving you the one thing
with all the best things alright one
tasty scoop of ag-1 contains 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients including a multi-vitamin
multi-mineral probiotic green superfood
blend and more in one convenient daily
serving i take it every day i drop it in
my water boom i'm out the door i'm
taking in my water bottles in the car
like a lot of times i really do forget
to drink water and i'm drinking soda or
whatever else so i take a water bottle
in the car now i put athletic greens in
it make sure i have it with me it's
lifestyle friendly so whether you eat
keto paleo vegan dairy free or
gluten-free it contains less than one
gram of added sugar no gmos no nasty
chemicals or artificial anything while
keeping it tasting good to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you an
immune supporting free one year supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase if you visit
athleticgreens.com honeydew today again
simply visit athleticgreens.com
honeydew to take control of your health
and give a.g one a try now let's get
back to the dew i heard a story one time
about jerry jones who owns the cowboys
one of his sons
i guess he gave him a bunch of like
money right
and he went to the titty bar
and took that money and said look here's
what we're gonna do
on the drive into the stadium there's a
bunch of billboards apparently on the
way in and he's like i can't give you
the one like right up by the stadium
because you're a titty bar but i could
give you about the third one in and he's
like but i could do it for this and
they're like
done so he made an agreement that they
would give him like stripper bucks
and they could put so he he made it
created a tab at the titty bar so they
could put their thing up there and then
he would just go there and get free lap
dances and drinks can you imagine that
unlimited time
[Laughter]
just you'd be like
i'm ready again yeah give me five five
of
them uh
yeah the the skydiving club uh so you
make a tab at this bar but did you ha
did you ever go skype
yeah we went uh and uh
scary [ __ ] the plane caught on fire it
was just the night it was
it was a nightmare playing god that's a
plane i would be happy to jump out
that's right
one of the funny things one of my
buddies who i can't talk about because
he's like
super successful businessman now in the
middle of like his turn to jump out you
you this is like a cessna and you're
doing static line jumps so you get out
all by yourself onto the wing you hold
on to the beam that holds the wing up
and then the jump master goes go and you
let go and you like fly out
he gets out on the wing and he goes wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait and they
pull him back in and he goes my shoulder
just popped out of its socket
and my friend kevin looks at me because
[ __ ]
and
think oh well we're sorry dude you know
like
we're gonna have to go into emergency
procedure and he's like huh they're like
we can't land with you in the plane it's
too much weight the plane can't land
with all this weight it can take off but
it can't land
so um
we're gonna need you to sit right on the
edge and just roll out like hold your
shoulder and roll out he's like but i i
can't it hurts too bad he's like just
hold your shoulder into place he's like
you're gonna roll out he's like the the
shoot will open and he's like and see if
you can then direct yourself down by
grabbing the toggles you know
so my friend's like he's like you have
to
so he's like three two one my friend
goes out and the guy looks at me the
jump master and goes works every time
i'm gonna say what plane can't land with
one person
so
what happened
was we i had literally the editor of the
newspaper on my skydiving club
i had the president of the student
government board i had oh you had the
head of the allocations committee i
so one of my fraternity brothers was
dating this girl who was you know that
she was like uh
what's her name from nancy pelosi
she just wanted to look into everything
and find out where there was injustice
the editor of the newspaper came after
or the assistant editor of the newspaper
came after it first she's like going to
write this big article about it
the editor of the newspaper buries it he
now works at politico
[Laughter]
he's doing that [ __ ] earlier he buries
the the article
they come after him for burying the
article and i'm like oh we're [ __ ]
going down and i remember uh
like i was threatening people i went up
to the girl the assistant editor i was
like i know you cheated on your
boyfriend i'll let him know like don't
you dare then this other girl came at me
from the uh the allocations committee
and she's like i know what you're up to
eddie if i know what you're up to and i
was like [ __ ] you and her boyfriend's
with her and i'm looking at him he's my
fraternity brother i'm like i'm gonna
beat your ass like why are you letting
her do this to us we're all having a
great time yeah for real and uh
she now works for hillary clinton
they're all doing that
and
i like see here on facebook and i'm just
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you ruined my
skydiving club
uh so i got in trouble university like
you know and it was embarrassing and and
then i finished i graduated but
you know it was just like fail fail fail
fail fail fail
and when i first did stand up like i
went to work for my dad and i failed i
couldn't like my dad's like i'm giving
you the business and i'm like i'm f
gonna
run you into bankruptcy like don't let
me touch it like everything i even like
my dad wanted me so badly to take over
his company and he's got like an
investment company i was like dad
we both know this isn't gonna work
like
you know just i'm i'm a nightmare and uh
i i
interned in washington dc for a senator
and just got kind of removed from that
and i was like literally like what the
[ __ ] am i gonna do and i i was like
maybe i'm just gonna go out to colorado
and be a ski bum you know because
i can do that and i'll just like be a
bartender or something and
because it was just failure after object
failure so when i found stand-up
i did i think my first open mic at the
funny bone in pittsburgh in station
square
and then
night
the first night they told me they go
this isn't your first time i'm like yeah
it is it's my first time and i've i had
that like the light hit me the laughs
came yeah i had some people have an
awful first i had an amazing first five
minutes i didn't get a bad one till like
five in
but the first one i was hooked i was
like and they said can you come back and
host
after my first that's how i got it and i
was like pay me 50 bucks that was it i
think i got 50 bucks guess what what
year was that yeah
they still pay you 50 [ __ ] dollars
bro they still face
unbelievable that they get away with it
they'll pay you 50.
it should be examined by the department
of justice that's what the people that
were looking into your goddamn [ __ ]
uh skydiving club should look into
comedy clubs that's what they should
look into every time i look at an opener
or feature and they're coming with i'm
just like what's wrong with you like why
would you go through this this is not
worth this pain that you're going to go
through to get here the 50th show i i
first time i did stand up i was 20 years
old so in 1993 wow you started young but
i i did it for like five shows and then
a bunch of life happened i didn't do it
it really started again until 27 okay
but the first time i really stepped foot
i did i did okay enough that they
invited me back and i would say by the
third time they asked me to host and it
was 50 bucks was that maryland 93 yeah
in baltimore where did you go in this
was a place that doesn't even exist
now it was before i was too i didn't
wasn't even [ __ ] with that i was went
to this um
place called winchester's that was above
this italian restaurant off of water
street and um it's not there anymore i
stopped in recently and they the people
in there didn't even know it was up
there before you know i'm like no i was
like no it was next door i'm like it was
right here right here upstairs where are
you at 93 i mean what is that 2015 wow
we're coming up on 30 years they're
still paying people 50 it's terrible
yeah it's not right anyway
yeah so then
quickly
i
probably was a lot
i i think i was better than i was like
we all do i
i thought i was great i probably sucked
i mean i don't even want to see tapes of
myself but i'm probably so bad
but
i had an ego i had
optimism i had i fi like i was getting
laughs
and
people were booking me other comics were
giving me [ __ ] right off the bat because
they're like who's this new guy that
[ __ ] think see you know
and some of them were taking me in
somewhere but i after like i don't know
how many months like six months lewis
black came through and he was headlining
imc'd for him and he was like what are
you doing here
he's like go to new york or l.a he's
like you're gonna get on saturday night
live
he's like you're young you're like you
gotta look and i was just yeah i didn't
know there was a world outside of
pittsburgh i mean i knew but i didn't
know comedy and i didn't know it was
accessible
and he was like no no you go to new york
or you go and you're gonna go to
auditions and you're gonna and i was
like
hmm
and
so i decided i'm like i'm going
and i went to new york and i mean i hit
my first audition ever
and uh
it was like everything came so [ __ ]
easy
that i started partying like crazy and i
was just i remember in my head thinking
what's everybody talking about the show
business being so hard i was like this
is the easiest thing i've ever done i go
to an audition i get it and then they
pay me and
like in the you know i paid my dues for
a little bit like a tiny little bit in
the beginning you know waited tables for
like a week then i tempt and i was a
personal trainer
but
like i think within my first year i hit
i was the host of shark week
and then i booked like three national
spots on commercials yeah so i had money
coming in
and i was just doing gigs like going
around and then you know the clubs in
new york started booking me i got
montreal
[Music]
uh in 2000.
so i'd only been doing comedy for like
three years
i think i started 96 so four years
and i still haven't got montreal are you
kidding me i've never been to montreal
that's i'm not a comedy store regular
i've never been to com uh montreal
uh aspen back when that was a thing none
of that stuff but it's so funny how
you're more successful than like
90 percent of the people that have done
those i mean maybe i am i guess yeah i
mean it's like we all have our thing
because there's things that get me that
i still can't do
and i'm like stop
like
i try to just be grateful but it takes
you it takes you years of being in this
business to also realize oh that was
that's just not for me yeah but you know
like
dane cook and uh what's his name louis
ck we're never comedy store regulars
right you know like
i just remember how many people sd
passed on at at the comedy seller how
many people um
uh what's his name uh
i can't remember his name but the comic
strip was like the hardest thing and
everybody got [ __ ] axe there and then
there were people that you're like how
does he work here so it's just you know
it's so subjective
yeah but um
they uh so things were moving swift and
quick for you and you thought it was
gonna be easy it got so easy i swear to
god i've never had a run where i fought
that at all like
you realize now though right obviously
with hindsight that you're lucky to even
have that run something like that in
this business oh [ __ ] yeah yeah but i
had no idea right i was driving which
might be the best way to do this anyway
i was driving fast i was drinking all
the time i was driving so fast when i'd
be out driving around like 140 miles an
hour whatever like that i just felt like
i i needed a buzz in life because that
wasn't even doing it anymore like i
started booking stuff and i was like
this is so easy
and i start going out on movie auditions
i get call backs on this i booked
i got a development deal
i got
well i had a development deal i got put
on a show on vh1 i got a pilot
sold to fx and i had a pilot with comedy
central that i was the host that's a
good 10 years
it all happened in like a year that's
insane
and it all crumbled
within six months
and when i say crumbled
why it [ __ ]
the development deal my writer walked
off to go work on i think it was how i
met your mother or something and he just
had a better deal he didn't like my show
he liked that show and so he gave his
money back and went to that show
then
the vh1 show got cancelled
the
the uh
but my manager kind of [ __ ] it up too
he was like negotiating and like asking
for weight it's like vh1 they've got
like 20 bucks and he's like i want
flights to all his colleges and back so
he can get back in time and i was doing
co i was making a really good living i
had a morning radio show on wnew uh
which was opie and anthony were
afternoons i was mornings damn yeah it
was all like and i'm like five years
four years into the business the comics
in new york wanted to murder
murder me and i was arrogant as [ __ ]
because i didn't know any better
and i remember sitting i remember i got
in a fight with like rich voss one time
we were like arguing back and forth and
i love rich and think he's one of the
funniest guys in the world
but back then they picked on me so bad
that i was just like [ __ ] all of them i
remember him just insulting me one night
like you're not funny and blah blah blah
and i was like you want to compare bank
accounts
[Laughter]
and i was like yeah you want to old man
you know i was like that was my like
you're hurting me i'm gonna hurt you
and i remember like patrice and all
these guys just wanting to kill me for
this
and
i didn't know any better
and uh and i was just like doesn't this
happen to everybody like i thought they
were all in my situation kind of like i
saw gaffigan doing all these commercials
and judah friedlander and i was like i'd
go out and book a commercial all you
know like i watch tv and i'd sometimes
have like two commercials on right after
each other
and
on top of it i was living with my sister
who was like a wall street person had
this two-story apartment and i didn't
pay rent oh god [ __ ] you i want to say
[ __ ] you sitting here listening i was
rich
i was like i was
and i was just
out partying every night spending tons
of money like it was like
i would go do a gig and then i would
go i'd go do a bunch of gigs i worked
really hard i loved doing stand-up i
loved auditioning but then i would just
go out and party all night like in the
hot night clubs and i knew all these
like models and everything
and then literally when it crashed
it kept they kept coming in like phone
call after phone call
i remember in the development deal i was
like so we just get another writer and
they're like no it's over i'm like what
do you mean it's over like it's over
they're like it's done it's next season
and i was like
and i was like well i still got all
these other things i get a call like vh1
canceled that show and i was like
okay i still got my pilot with comedy
central and they're like comedy central
is not picking up the pilot and i was
like i still sold the show to vh1
the show we sold our fx was a show about
sneaking into places called balls me and
a bunch of friends made the show where
we would gate crash things
911 happens oh yeah it ain't happening
my manager agent at the time who's
babydoll dixon uh jimmy kimmel's manager
they always talk he calls me he's like
it's over
i'm like what is he's like your show i
go no no i just talked to the producers
it's fine he goes now
because you really think people in this
environment want to see a bunch of guys
sneaking into places he's like you're
done you're canceled i'm like no they
told us we're not and he goes you want
to bet he goes i'll bet you and like two
days later he's like i told you
so they canceled that and then the only
thing i had left i was in seinfeld's
movie comedian
and i had this really funny scene with
jerry where i intro jerry and we kind of
had this little tit for tat kind of
thing
and they paid me they called me hey
you're in seinfeld's movie come down and
pick up your check the director i had
done a commercial for hey
i was like oh okay well i'm in this
little documentary that's gonna be in
the movie theaters
i see jerry's manager at a party one
night and we're talking i said oh yeah i
said i'm in the film he goes hmm i go
yeah i'm in the film
no you're not i go yeah i get i get paid
for it and everything i he goes now they
just got 18 minutes out
and i was like
i thought the way they were canceling
this [ __ ]
with the the pilot with comedy central i
remember i thought it was terrible i was
like i can't believe i'm doing this it's
like the worst show i don't want to talk
about it badly because people are
involved that
like it you know and were involved and
worked hard on it but
i knew it was bad it was really [ __ ]
bad they strapped the camera on me
and and
it was called strap on and i uh uh yeah
and i had to like go and you know
i'd put the camera on other people and
then i would talk through their ear and
it was there were some funny concepts to
it but it just wasn't executed and it
was again it was just a pilot so maybe
the show would have really worked out
but they were like yeah you're up
against uh dave chappelle has a show
and uh
and uh colin quinn has a show and it's
you you're the three shows comedy
central's gonna decide and i was like
well i'm [ __ ] out and my manager was
like no actually you're the cheapest one
so you're probably gonna get picked up
and then
they're picking up one show so then i
get the call he's like yeah they
they picked up two shows
just not yours
i was like
this just kept happening every time i
started getting anxiety about seeing the
phone ringing i'll bet man
i was waiting i was waiting for my
parents to call me to tell me they
weren't my parents like you're adopted
it was
getting so bad that i swear to god i
started to get paranoid and i thought
i thought i might be part of a reality
show this is how paranoid i got and i
thought they're [ __ ] with me
they're [ __ ] with me right now
somebody's filming me or there's
something going on behind the scenes and
it's all going to be like told hey we
were this was like
a show we were shooting and we were
going to build you up and break you down
and
and i
i started to get weird and i was calling
and you know when you have that stink on
you
i had that stink on me so people i
started calling were like yeah i gotta
go
and no one wanted my auditions started
going away my agents were like ah you
know like didn't want me around and i
just felt like an abject failure like
everything
and i just was like in total fear and i
start going where's my money and i
remember
my girlfriend broke up with me and like
it just started getting really really
[ __ ] bad
and
i
i went home and like spent i never took
time off ever i took two weeks and went
on vacation in new jersey with my family
and i sat and like basically like
my dad's not a
empathetic or sympathetic person at all
emotional and i think i like cried to
him and i was like
i don't know what i did blah blah blah
and he's like you haven't worked hard
enough
you know my dad's like he's like you
work 40 hours a week i'm like i don't
have to he's like you're going to be a
failure for the rest of your life he's
like you can't do this and i was like no
you don't understand my business he's
like no i know business
and all business you have to work at
least 40 at least to make the minimum
he's like if you want to be successful
go work 80 hours a week
and i was just
i was in full panic mode because i
didn't know where my next dollar was
coming from
and uh and i was starting to get broke
because i lived off my development deal
money and i wouldn't travel because i
was like
hey i got this money and blah blah blah
so all my dates went away
and i just figured i'm getting a show
and i have this and when it went away it
went away quickly
and i still didn't have to pay rent my
sister was nice enough but there was
still you know you're living in new york
city it's hard
and when i was at montreal i met a guy
who was a british agent and he goes to
me
he was like came up he's like hello yeah
i find you very funny and i was like oh
well thank you you know i kind of mocked
him and he was like would you like to
come do some shows in england and i was
like no i would not
i'm going to be a hollywood superstar i
don't know if you've heard and uh he was
like well here's my card if you would
ever like to come and uh
i uh
i was sitting like
just like
losing my mind
and i like picked up his card and i
called him on the phone and i was like
hey dude
uh i remember his name his name was
danny julian i was like
can i come to england and do some shows
and he went sure i'll have this guy call
you back with uh your dates and blah
blah blah
and i get a call back and they're like
yeah we're gonna email your dates
they're like how long can you come and i
was like how long do you want me and
they're like three months that's how
long your visa is i was like okay
they sent me back with
three months of dates like every day
damn and it was at the time they were
paying about 200 pounds a show okay so
that was about close to 400 at the time
so it was 400 like every night of the
week and then double up some triple ups
on weekends and i'm like
this is amazing and i get to perform
which i love to do and i don't have to
do [ __ ] during the day i can go drink
beer i was like this is [ __ ] awesome
and i go over
the first weekends in uh birmingham
england i go to the glee club in
birmingham england i go on stage they
have me headlining
and i bomb
so
[ __ ]
hard
like so hard my mouth goes dry
like
i can't get words out i'm going
and i'm trying
to like talk and i can't talk i can't
remember any jokes
and i go in the green room and the stink
that i had before is like i i'd left the
stink back in new york but it flew over
for that night it was like
we found them we found them
and i'm in i'm in the green room and the
comics were like
like they went from talking to me before
the show to we're not talking to you
anymore
and you only do one show
and i was just like
oh i am [ __ ] terrible meeting with a
therapist to work on your mental health
is just as helpful as hiring a personal
trainer to work on your physical health
and the positive impact can be just as
life-changing talkspace makes it
possible to speak with a licensed
therapist right from your phone tablet
or computer and unlike traditional
therapy you can message your therapist
anytime via text video or voice it's a
hundred percent secure and stigma free
the way therapy should be look i you
know i believe in therapy i think it's
important for everyone we've all gone
through some things in life and not
everyone can relate to that so
um i agree wholeheartedly that we are
all out there trying to cut up our abs
and drop our double chins and boobs
everything else and we're not out there
working on our problems you're the same
person inside no matter what you do on
the outside so i i know a lot of stigma
with it and you know especially with men
like oh my dad wasn't like that not so
what so what be your own man and go work
on it if you need to work on it all
right
at talk space your privacy and security
are their number one priority the app
puts you in a private room with just you
and your therapist you can send messages
24 7 and get replies throughout the day
no need to wait for a weekly appointment
talk spaces encryption and added
security features keep your conversation
fully protected join talkspace today and
start moving forward with a single
message just visit talkspace.com and get
a hundred dollars off your first month
when you use the promo code honeydue
signup that's a hundred dollars off at
talkspace.com
promo code honeydew the holidays are
almost here and for all of you who are
trying to figure out what to get that
person who means so much to you i've got
the perfect gift enzo rings look these
are it right here these are stylish
silicone rings with a soft flexible fit
i'm wearing one right now they're so
much more comfortable and safer than
wearing a metal ring especially for
anyone active or who works with their
hands a lot comes in this cool little
case like this
uh i'm really surprised by it's flexible
look i got fat knuckles this thing went
right over and it looks good and don't
there's not just black okay so no matter
what your taste our enzo rings has you
covered with a wide selection of stylish
and fun collections like their elements
collection has an elegant look of real
metal but the benefits of silicone enzo
rings actually infuses real precious
materials into the silicone you can't
find this in any other silicone ring
brand there's platinum there's rose gold
there's diamond there's pearl there's
even volcanic ash and a lot more trust
me enzo rings are a gift that they'll
love check out enzo's elements rings and
other best sellers at my special url
enzorings.com honeydew that's e-n-s-o
rings dot com slash honeydew and for a
limited time you'll get 10 off your
first purchase of any collection when
you use the promo code honeydew don't
wait lock in your holiday orders now and
even get one for yourself for ten
percent off that's promo code honeydew
at ensorings.com
honeydew now let's get back to the duke
i wasn't suicidal i've never been
suicidal
but i was like
what do i do like do i do i jump on like
a cruise ship
to jamaica and just end up like
being that guy that like cuts coconuts
and like
i gotta go
somewhere i just felt like this guy that
i just failed so badly at hollywood and
i felt like i had failed and it was over
like hollywood had said
you're out you got your shot you're done
you're never allowed back in
and here i am like new country new start
nah not working here either show and i
went home and uh they had me in a
holiday inn that was like so [ __ ]
tiny the room was small way the room
with the bathroom was as small as this
damn and
i'm in the room
and uh
i have a breakdown i [ __ ] broke down
it was like uh the closest i've come to
like a mental breakdown in my life i
bawled my eyes out i uh
i was just like i have no money i have
no girlfriend my girlfriend had dumped
me i remember like right before that my
radio show had got well i left the radio
show because they were going to fire me
and i was like
i was like i'm going to hollywood and i
got this and this and this like i
thought i sold a script like
and
uh it was just
i'm in that hotel room and i'm like what
am i doing i'm in a foreign country
alone
i'm i think i was like almost
i was over 30 so i'm like all my friends
are getting married having kids i don't
have a dollar in the bank
i don't have a girlfriend
i have just [ __ ] up so badly and i was
like i've just made the biggest mistake
that my parents were trying to tell me
was gonna happen
and i didn't listen to them and here i
am and they they had warned me like
don't go into entertainment don't do
this come work here
and i was like
[ __ ] they were right
i thought i knew better than them and
i'm
a loser for the rest of my life and um
there's a funny story that i've done a
bit about it i pulled out a newspaper
and just started reading this like
random newspaper that they put outside
your room and i started reading about 9
11 and then this i was like i got to do
anything because i didn't have the
internet then you were in england when 9
11 happened no i was in new york when 9
11 happened but this was like after 9
11. i think it was the year anniversary
and so it'd be like uh this was
uh 2002 when i'm in england and i'm in
this hotel room in birmingham and i pull
out this newspaper to just read it to
get my mind off my nervous breakdown and
uh
i read this article about it was talking
about all these people that died
in 911 his year anniversary they
interviewed this one guy that lost his
wife he was a flight attendant
and he said uh
he i'm reading the article and right
away i went
all right time to put screw my head on
straight here are these people that have
like the most horrific thing that's ever
[ __ ] happened
and
i'm complaining because a bunch of
people booed me they did boom me off and
you've
they booed me off the stage they booed
me off oh it was it got louder and
louder and louder
pretty sure it started as hissing
and then it went to booing
and then it went to just me slithering
offstage
but i'm like i don't have it so bad you
know like i gotta put my head on
straight yeah so i'm reading more and
the guy says
that uh he lost his wife she was one of
the flight attendants in one of the
planets he goes they had a they had a
great life together and he was happy for
that because one of the things about
their relationship they always laughed
how important laughter was and i was
like ah you know that's what i try to do
i try to make people laugh
and then he said
uh
he was
their last night together before she
died before she was on the plane they
were at a comedy club
and uh
uh
they were at a comedy club and
he said he was just glad that they had
that night together because she was
laughing so hard tears were coming out
of her eyes and he had mentioned that he
was stand up new york cause i think she
flew out to boston then flew back i
forget what it was um because i think
she was on the flight that came from
boston
and he said he was glad that they had
that night together because that's what
he'll always remember is just like her
laughing so i had a palm pilot at the
time i open up my palm pilot
i'm on all my manager at the time was at
that time was carrie hoffman from
stand-up new york
i worked his club constantly and i'm
like stand in new york i always worked
stand-up new york yeah that's weird they
were there i open up the date i look i
worked all three shows hell yeah and i'm
like
this is great and i don't i don't
believe in sigh i believe in coincidence
and i'm like
wait a minute
this could be like
something from that something say bigger
than a coincidence yeah i'm like this is
a sign
that
something's like
that this is and then i just started to
gain perspective i'm like you aren't
like
his wife's dead my career is dead
this [ __ ]
i'm killing people
not only is my career dying but anybody
that sees me is dying
i fed up i found
the glee club at jungler's burned down
or at the birmingham burned down after i
left everybody in it no i've uh
i was like
it honestly was that little thing that i
went okay
change your perspective it's not about
the money and the success and the
partying and the girls and the [ __ ]
this and that it's about why did you
start this you wanted i honestly wanted
to make people laugh i love making
people laugh that's why i did it so i
was like just [ __ ] make people laugh
and i was like that's all this is about
and i don't give a [ __ ] if i make
another dollar i don't give a [ __ ] about
whatever it is and i remember i was
going home to like my i forget it was
like my ten year i think it was my 10
year
15 year i forget high school and high
school
and um
reunion and i was like so worried about
going home and just doing everybody
going like what are you doing
nothing
no nothing and um
so i go the next night i got to go to
the glee club or the glee club and
perform in birmingham and they've moved
me to feature
they've bumped me down from headlines
and i find out all my dates
have changed now that i'm no longer the
headline after one show yeah and i'm
like
and they were like oh it's okay you're
still gonna get paid the same amount but
uh we just think maybe it'd be better if
you go on before the and i was like
[ __ ]
so i i get a little angry
and it was a lot of like this is right
around the war so it was a lot of like
oh you [ __ ] american blah blah blah
and so i'm mad now and i go on stage and
instead of being like i'm sorry i'm an
american i went on stage now and i'm an
american and they went boo and i go boo
boo you got [ __ ] blood on your hands
too you're over in [ __ ] iraq and
afghanistan with us and i'm like you
[ __ ] boomy you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] and
i just start hammering them
and all of a sudden oh yeah like they
they start coming around
philly thing yeah it was just and the
same exact jokes that i got booed on
they start
clapping stomping going berserk and it
was to this day one of the best sets
i've ever had i went from the worst set
i've ever had to one of the best sets
i've ever had
and i walk off stage
and you know they do intermissions and
everything i go to the green room i'm
all happy you know like i'm not going to
get sent home i was thinking i was
getting sent home and i'm like they're
not going to send me i'm in the green
room and the uh
the mc goes uh
tony law i know the guy still to this
day he goes uh eddie if
the crowd's steer and they're stomping
on the ground boom boom boom boom boom
and i don't know what
we don't do that
and he's going eddie if and they're
stomping and i'm like and he goes eddie
aft and i'm like the [ __ ] happening so
he comes he runs into the green room and
he grabs me pulls me outside i want you
to come out they wanted me to do an
encore which they do in the uk and
australia but we don't do that so i
didn't know so you're doing five more
minutes yeah yeah you do so i come out
on stage they're all standing i'm
getting a standing ovation i walk out on
stage and i go
i wave
and i walk off
so the crowd that was like
so excited for me to come back out i
just insult them again there you go
and i walk off so then he closes the
show down for the intermission or
whatever and he comes back and he goes
what the [ __ ] why wouldn't you encore
and i go huh he was why didn't you
encore they went i'm like encore
what
like a band and he's like yeah and he
goes you're supposed to do like five
more minutes and i was like
oh i go well i already did my best [ __ ]
i don't know i didn't have anything
to slow down
i didn't have anything good left anyways
[ __ ] my [ __ ] for the life
so
i do then that was the weekend the next
week and i'm back to headlining
and i was like okay they like i survived
that the switch
and my agent told me he was like yeah
you're a little worried you know the
club called and said how bad it went
blah blah blah
but i went home with this like newfound
kind of like i worked in england for
like three months and just had the best
[ __ ] time it was just all about
comedy it's all i cared about i didn't
give a [ __ ] about auditions i didn't
care of tv i didn't money nothing it was
just like they would wire money into my
account and it was all about a comic in
england said it to me once i was like so
how do we get on tv over here and he's
like why would you want to get on tv
i'm like
it's what we do in america he's like
you're performing live every night
you're getting paid well what do you why
do you want more and i was like because
he's like you're so american
and i was like yeah like why do i want
more this is awesome this is amazing
like why should i want anything else
other than this
so i came back to america with that
attitude of like i'm just gonna try to
be a really good comic that's what i'm
gonna try to do and not listen to
anybody else and blah blah blah and the
joke i tell on stage is i contacted the
dude
uh who was in that article man i was
hoping i was gonna ask you okay good so
i wanted to let them know out of the
terrible tragedy like this little bit of
good happened that i was continue
performing and like going around all
over the world trying to make people
laugh
just so like there'd be
laughter in life and uh so i contacted
the guy and uh
and uh the guy agreed to meet me for
coffee
and uh so when i showed up where where
were you meeting upper wassad so he was
from the upper west that's why i was at
standup new york when i showed up at the
uh
coffee shop i was outside i walk up and
right outside the fence he's all i'm
outside the fence he's he goes
oh my god no he's like i totally
remember you from the show oh i got
chills dude he
you're the one guy my wife didn't like
[Laughter]
oh well whatever change your goddamn
life
you're the one and i was like she was
probably at the like early show i'm
better on the late show
oh
man
yeah
and you know what it hasn't
it hasn't gotten any i mean i've had ups
and downs since then and it still
happens
it's like i mean you know we all know
it's i always think back to i don't know
if you've seen her documentary but the
joan rivers documentary there's two
points there's two moments that really
stand out in that one was her
she had her like day runner and she
would just show like
months of blank pages months of blank
pages
um
[Music]
and then the other one is i was i still
laugh about it it's one of the funniest
things it was uh her manager at the time
was saying that he also had managed
richard pryor
and it was that whole like you don't we
don't know what the look i need to eat
tomorrow okay i need to eat tomorrow not
pay bill i need to [ __ ] eat have a
place to a roof over my head and he was
like okay richard and i'm paraphrasing
but it was something like you know first
year two we're gonna work on some
stand-up kitchen doing some tv spots and
specials year three maybe we'll get you
into the movies year four year five and
he was like look man that all sounds
great but what the [ __ ] are we gonna do
about monday
and it has just that is i'm like yes
that is the hustle mentality yeah and
all that sounds [ __ ] great but what
are we doing about monday i felt like
everyone i worked with in this business
was like that too
and you know i go to these agencies and
they'd be like turning down
all this work for me
because they're like no you we we can't
take that money we have to get big money
for you and i'm like but no one's paying
right and they're like just
just sit and wait
and it'll come
be patient and i'm like
i can't [ __ ] be patient yeah and then
they're like you got to stay in town for
the auditions i'm like i can't i gotta
go
i gotta go to this gig i gotta go get
this and they're like can't you borrow
money
i'm like right no no no have you seen
you know like have you seen my credit
you know like no
no comic can borrow money no comme you
know i guess there are some guys out
there that have rich parents and when
they do
like
my parents were probably upper middle
class they wouldn't give me a [ __ ]
dollar my dad said if you're gonna do
this you do it on your own and don't
ever come to me for a dollar and never
gave me a dollar
and
i never went to him because out of pride
so i would like when i first lived in
new york city my first like when i first
got there before like i got my
commercial i would i would have no money
i would take the bottles and cans from
our parties and take them in to get the
money to go buy lunch that day
and
you know because no one was paying me to
do stand-up at that point and it was
just such a struggle i'm sorry i'm still
thinking
the story of my life
[Laughter]
and then you gotta sit and have coffee
with the guy you're walking up and he
hit you with that yeah you gotta
hey
i remember you
you're the guy that
oh yeah dude all right
first of all thank you for doing this hi
thanks for having me um thanks for
letting me get the therapy you got it
brother i do want to ask you it's your
first time here i ask everybody advice
you'd give to your 16 year old self like
knowing what you know what we just
talked about now
going back
what would you definitely tell 16 year
old eddie if it's funny you asked me
because when i leave here i've got a
phone conversation with a friend's son
who is 15 years old
who wants to be a comedian
and i'm giving him like
some advice he wants to be like an snl
writer
performer kind of thing and i auditioned
for snl like three years into comedy
which i shouldn't have
or
i should have gone balls out
i was so in my head about that
like i'm not ready for this i'm not
funny enough for this blah blah blah and
so i just killed myself i either should
have gone into like i'm the funniest
[ __ ] guy in the world or i gotta wait
till i am the funniest guy in the world
um but i would say
you know
16 year old me
i just say
you're gonna get knocked down a million
times a million times and it's just like
rocky just you gotta get up and you just
gotta fight because it's all it's life
it's like you know i've just dealt with
you know a death in the family uh
i'm put this way it's like the best of
my life right now is the best it's ever
been yeah at the same time it's the
worst that's ever i mean my mom just
passed and my but i love my wife i love
my kids i love where i live i love my
friend but like then i'll get like i
just had bronchitis where i was coughing
and thought i was [ __ ] dying of like
something and
you know
you're gonna get hit every day with good
[ __ ] and you're gonna get hit every day
with bad [ __ ] my dad always says life's
running hurdles on a treadmill uphill
amen to that and if you stop the hurdles
are gonna hit you and knock you down so
you just gotta keep jumping over them
and
you're just gonna
be at a level and wherever that level is
just be happy at that level because the
levels are going to change
and if you decide you can only be level
at a happy at a high level
then you're going to be [ __ ]
miserable yeah so find happiness
wherever you are and uh
and just
get ready for struggles
and get through them because the good
times are gonna come back again
and it's gonna go good it's gonna go bad
it's gonna go good
and
you know this business just keep
flipping over the stones because
who knows
who this [ __ ] didn't even exist when we
started yeah that's right i never knew i
never i never wanted this
i kind of love this for a reason for
that
but it wasn't what i wanted
so i'm i still sometimes have that
mentality of like when am i getting my
sitcom and i'm like
it's not coming anyway the last
development deal meeting i went on in
the middle of it they looked at me and
they went is it a deal breaker if you
don't star in the show
you mean an eddie if story yeah
and i was like
somehow
and they were like
they're like is it a deal breaker and i
went
at first i was so butthurt i was like
about to get up and be like
like are you kidding me you came to my
show you saw what i do and you don't
you want to buy my my concept
you know
it's me
and then two seconds into that it
quickly kicked in i'm like wait you mean
i'm never gonna have to study lines i
don't have to put makeup on a trailer
all the time i was like you just gave me
my dream job and i was like all mailbox
money and i said i go
oh it's kind of a deal breaker if you
make me be in the show
i was like can we can we can we do it
that i
don't want to be in the show and they're
like
yeah and then afterwards everybody's
like hold on they slow down slow down
and i was like
no i really
don't think i i love hanging out with my
kids
and i don't want to be away from them
all the time and i don't want to
like i don't want to miss out in life
yeah like i i would love to make a great
tv show but
i don't want to be on set 24 hours a day
and filming and going into late i go
that's that's i don't enjoy acting
enough yeah
so
well dude thank you for doing this hey
thank you i love it i love your show
promote everything you'd like yeah go uh
am i special come come to the taping
irvine improv
uh january 22nd ticket's gonna go on
sale soon because i gotta fill it for
two shows and that's a big room to do it
uh
and then my
my newest album is out it's called sweet
home alabama and it's uh it's available
on youtube and everywhere else itunes
amazon and then also uh my tour is at
eddief.com so i'll be everywhere and if
you're into working out i do a podcast
called wadcaster i know i don't look
like it
but
but i do i work out constantly i'm hurt
always
all right brother thank you hey thank
you thank you thanks for having me
you're welcome and as always ryan
sickler on all social media ryan
sickler.com we'll talk to you all next
week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you